it's really great to be here today this
is a mostly brand new talk that would be
a remixed of old themes and so since
this is all brand new I wanted to bring
some tomatoes in case it's all really
bad you can throw them at me but it was
really nice and helping me set up all
the a/v and so I didn't want to make a
mistake of having them make a big mess
so here you get him get a tomato - all
right so that they're good so if it's
all the big mess you can throw the
tomatoes and I'm actually really much
looking for feedback on a lot of these
ideas it's it's stuff I've been thinking
about and as you may have read in
abstract when I was a kid and there was
something where I didn't know what it
was I would ask my folks what it was and
you know they were they're kind of
snarky and so they would say oh it's a
it's a question maker and that seems
evasive but I think it's also kind of
brilliant because it was literally true
I mean you know it was a thing I didn't
know what it was asked a question and in
a lot of ways I think that's what I
think one of the biggest mistakes that
people make about design is that we
often think that designers make stuff
and in a lot of ways I think what design
does is it makes questions I gave a talk
in Symphony Hall in downtown San Diego
or guess about two years ago now and I
don't normally speak to more pop
audiences and so I was like oh
everybody's gonna be bored by my more
esoteric examples so I hopped on
Facebook and I said what examples do you
have of prototyping from your own life
and you reckon you may recognize a lot
of these folks in fact James is on here
you know so a lot of people like Eric's
on did Park gave an example of building
a prototype of a renovation of Bruce
house a lot of people had various
digital devices where they prototype
making something different there but
here's all my favorites so two alums
from here former students from a group
and Jesse prototype whether if they put
a TV on the wall whether they would have
room for the plant and I think it's
really beautiful just like that and they
were actually inclined to keep it I
think it's kind of cool better still
Marianna d.school alum said you know
idea I prototype living with my man for
three months before we moved in together
a great idea somebody else did the joint
big big big sisters to prototype
Parenthood great idea and Alexander is
an alum from here who's now a PhD
student at CMU so I got a temporary
tattoo before I got the real tattoo and
I mean I think that's just a great idea
these are really cool and I think about
for a number of years I've thought about
creativity as I kind of simulated
annealing that you want to have a hot
phase where you bounce around a lot and
then there's gonna be a cool phase where
things are more stable and what I think
is really interesting about this in fact
this is work with Trish anoon and Karen
Walker and Karen's former adviser Alison
Gopnik is also really keen on this this
simulated annealing idea she has a
recent op-ed on this that's really good
so everything's kind of interesting
about this is that we're not very good
at it this is this is my candidate for a
creativity cognitive bias and and I'll
show you an example of that from a study
that Steve and I Dow and I ran here
several years ago that still got to be
my favorite video to ever come out of a
study and we had people build these egg
drop devices they threw him out of my
office window and we would see whether
they survived and what was interesting
is people came up with all sorts of
stuff like some were great some were
terrible all sorts of different designs
but when you talk to people individually
what they would say is stuff like this
no I don't know for some reason this
this seems to be the only idea there
needs to be a platform and then it's
gonna push it as possible with the
materials I don't see any of any other
way I am NOT a very good outside the box
think there should I kind of just had
one idea and I was gonna try and make it
work this is the best approach for such
a design so I I really love this because
all of us have been this person and one
of the things that's interesting there's
one theory about academia that you study
the thing that you don't understand or
that you're not natively good at and I
definitely in studying creativity I feel
like I experienced these errors a lot
and in particular what I've seen from
you know as James mentioned I've been
teaching design a while now and one
really common error among novice
designers is to cool too easily that we
well the first idea we come to that we
think is reasonably good really great
got it I'm gonna move forward with this
and then when I get stuck I'm gonna be
like oh and I get rid of my idea
two-thirds of the way through the
quarter and then I try a new one and
Bill Verplank who I talk with for
several years is nodding like yep that's
what happens and and so I think for me
that becomes kind of the core of the
design early ethos that that you know
the title for today is question makers
and the first meaning of that is that
the object is a question maker the the
second one is that the way that I think
about what designers do is that
designers are question makers that's
kind of what the profession is and
another another person some folks might
know here is this is Mike Mike was an
undergraduate and master's student
working with me and actually T aid my
undergraduate class one of the very
first times I taught it and we did
mobile devices and Mike afterwards
started a mobile company and with a
friend of his and they built this app
called bourbon
and it was this was the early days of
the iPhone and you had a camera but the
camera wasn't very good and Mike was
pretty smart and so he knew a couple of
things one of the things that he knew
was that people are going to want to
share pictures with their friends
they're gonna want to do so in a
location way and they're only going to
want to share pictures with people that
they're really close to they're gonna
want to share things that are kind of in
the moment and bourbon kind of flopped
and one of the things that I think is
really interesting about design that I
don't have any concrete answers to but
I'll try and sketch out a few strategies
is what do you do in the particular
thing that you've made kind of flops
your hypothesis flops your artifact
flops whatever one thing you could say
is oh this would be great if we just
changed the typefaces all we got to do
is fix the fonts and then this is going
to be awesome you know another thing you
could say is you could say smartphone
apps are stupid I'm gonna go do
something else entirely and then there's
a whole range of world in between and
and in terms of like the kind of
studying the theoretical underpinnings
of design visa vie a simulated annealing
model I think one really hard question
at any turn is how high should your
entropy be sure you want to cool it over
time but but it won't weigh at how and
Mike went back to the drawing board
actually literally just for some of his
sketches and he and Kevin built this app
called Instagram that I'm guessing a lot
of people here how many people use
Instagram out of curiosity Wow
I pull when I teach a guest lecture in
the freshman class at UCSD and I've
pulled for years people on what social
networks they use and it's interesting
to see things evolve over over time this
year Instagram was the most dominant
which was which was interesting and so
what I think is neat about this
Instagram example is it not like Mike
made bourbon it flopped and then they
made this other one and it was great
what happened was that among many other
things
one of my successes in terms of the
design strategy here is that remember
Mike knew that you would only want to
share photos with your close friends but
Mike also knew that the stuff that you
were going to share was kind of mostly
trivial what I had for lunch and that
sort of thing and so building an auth
model into it from day one wasn't
mission-critical and so Mike built an
early prototype of Instagram and they
released it out in the world and they
didn't bother with the auth model
because you know we know how to do that
we'll do that later and one thing that
was really interesting is one of the
early Instagram users was a photographer
in Hawaii who would take these sunset
pictures and all of a sudden everybody
on Instagram is following this guy in
Hawaii
who's taking sunset pictures and Mike's
like huh that's not what we thought was
gonna happen and what I really like
about this example is that as we know
Instagram today has lots of people
following lots of people and that's a
very common use case it's not what was
expected out of the gate and the way
that mike was able to learn that was not
by imagining it ahead of time but by
getting a draft out into the world
before before they were ready and so the
way that I think about a lot of this
stuff is that design creates postcards
from the future that you you'd launch
yourself into a future and live in that
future and then send back a dispatch
from that future to to the current time
and this can be for making something new
like like Instagram Virginia Eubanks it
at SUNY Troy has done some great work
looking at how surveillance capitalism
affects the working class and is the
kind of reality that many of us might be
living in the future and she takes that
wonderful William Gibson quote that the
future is already here it's just not
evenly distributed which often we think
about oh you're like let's go to Xerox
PARC and see what Bill Verplank
friends are up to what's due card and
and Virginia kind of flips that on its
head and says well you know there's a
lot of other communities that are living
in a different future that may be a
little bit more dystopian but in either
case we get these postcards and then we
can decide what to do with them and I
think this back and forth this
negotiation is is key to design and
maybe is the piece that is one of the
more difficult things to learn in both
participants this is a an image from
Donaldson's the reflective practitioner
where he looks at the back-and-forth
conversation of an architect professor
professor and an architecture student
and what you see is that the students as
well maybe the building will go on the
hillside here these are contour lines
and then the professor shows some
alternative ways that it might work and
what shouldn't cause this conversation
with materials and again you get you see
this idea of an artifact being used as a
communicative or a communicative
function more than as an artifact
function you sit in the chair it's
mostly playing a role as a chair even
you stand on something that we wouldn't
call a chair it's mostly playing a role
as a chair but here it's mostly playing
a discursive role one of the most
exciting things going on
UCSD right now is we just broke ground
on a new design innovation building
74,000 square feet and it's going to be
right where the light rail station
arrives on campus which is really cool
and I've worked really closely helping
to select the architects and I've been
working with the architects for a long
time and the folks at ahdd are really
great they're actually up right along
the Embarcadero in San Francisco here
and one of the ways that we would work
together you can see here's the
interesting one is that they would put
together a floor plan for the building
and then I would go and depending on
where we were what I felt like sometimes
I would go in keynote or and sometimes
we'd print things out and clip them up
and I would say okay you know here's the
design that you had here's my reworking
of that in a different way and you can
see hopefully on the left so these are
foreign different designs that they came
up with and then I reworked this left
one to achieve some goal and what's
interesting about that is that nothing
that I could put together is something
you would ever want to build in a
building like my ideas aren't actually
good that's not their role but what they
do is that by putting it an artifact
form it lets the architects understand
what I'm asking for and they say oh I
see what your concern about the previous
draft was and I see what you're after
the way a talented person would do that
is this and being able to see that back
and forth you know sometimes
undergraduates go on spring break to
like Florida or Cancun or something a
couple years ago I went on spring break
it was a visiting scholar at Harvard and
I hung out a bunch in the Graduate
School of Architecture here where all of
the students are in the same room and so
you can see these back and forth s--
really viscerally and as James mentioned
one thing that I've been thinking about
a lot is how can you scale this kind of
amazing interactive experience you know
that that I had with the architects that
the Harvard graduate students have how
can you scale that and I think that one
reason that scaling open-ended work is
challenging and I'm really curious in
particular to hear what folks think
about these ideas is that there are some
things that are pretty straightforward
hopefully three plus four equals seven
there's 16 ounces in a pound you know
there are things that that to a first
approximation will just call true facts
and then there are things where you know
something like the strength of a design
or a poem or a piece of art where it
wouldn't entirely make sense to publish
a book of all the world's art where you
rank it on a zero to 100 point scale I
mean that's just not
that's not what it's about it's more
multi-dimensional than that that doesn't
mean that all works of art have an equal
claim to being amazing or great and
ditto for designs and and so it's not I
think often people are really tempted to
say look we got the facts and then we
got things that are just your opinion in
your opinion whatever man and I think a
lot of stuff a lot of the interesting
stuff lives in that middle ground and my
favorite example of this is that I was
fortunate enough of years ago to have
dinner with the great theoretical
computer scientist David tarnish and you
know she she'd she and I were talking
and she's like you know it's really
interesting is that I've chaired the the
theoretical computer science conference
basically a math conference and all of
the submissions are proofs and most of
them are true you know there's a few
where people got an oopsie in there but
mostly they're true and so the job of
the program committee is to decide which
of these are the most
consequentially interesting which will
move the field forward the most and I
love that example of a field that we
think of as hard in a sense that the
selection criteria are objective and
what Ava's saying is know that that in
fact what we're doing is it's much more
taste driven and that's not to say and
so a different group of people might
make a different set of decisions that's
not to say that all endeavors haven't
have an equal claim and so with some
folks here we put together an online
class and and had the first chance to do
global scale peer review and I talked
about this more the last time I was here
so I'm not going to talk about the
system parts of this today but I'm happy
to field questions one thing that's neat
I met with our liaison at Coursera a
couple days ago we had coffee and the
peer review system that chinmaya and
daphne and i designed here in 2012 12
now
Coursera sees 4,000 new submissions
every day and now these numbers are out
of date a little bit the
more than 1,400 courses use peer review
and that's neat because you can have all
of these creative fields where people
are able to get feedback one thing
that's interesting and I think this will
recur a little bit is I think one of the
great riddles of the learning Sciences
is that people are essentially built to
like learning that's like if you're
gonna if you're gonna build a human if
you're gonna engineer a human one of the
key attributes of it is that you enjoy
learning that you know from the from the
biology on up
we value surprise when things are not
what we expect that's exciting and we
pursue novel experiences given that it's
really weird to me that we don't like
learning in the way that is most
effective for us to learn that a lot of
the learning strategies will pursue left
to our own devices are pretty lousy
learning strategies and the ones that
are more metacognitively difficult
things like peer review is one example
students sometimes find aversive for the
amount of work that's involved and so
it's a I think that's an interesting
riddle one thing that's been fun about
this line of work is that you know when
I met James one of the the we did we'd
achieved a world where user centered
design was starting to become more
common but it was the early days of the
web and a lot of software you know for
example if you've got Microsoft Office
it showed up on a cd-rom and what that
meant was that Microsoft had no idea
what anybody did with their software
after they released it and I think
that's one of the bigger shifts that
we've seen in design in recent years is
that
for starters now researchers have the
opportunity in some cases to get stuff
that you can use it's scale you know
Michaels group and others have some
great examples of this and also the
ability to get feedback on what's
happening in terms of real use I think
is super important and it also I think
shifts the designers role in some
interesting ways here's a fun this is
super fun this is an example I love from
the New York Times a couple years ago
this is a sequence of numbers 2 4 8 and
it obeys a rule and if anybody has a
guess of three numbers I'll tell you
whether it opens the rule and if you
think you know the rule at any point you
can raise your hand to any yeah 3 9 81
obeys the rule thank you I have 5 to 6 5
to 6 does not obey the rule yeah 1 1 1
does not obey the rule 1 2 3 what does
he carry on base the rule 3 6 9 a base
to roll negative 1 0 1 base a little 7 8
9 7 8 9 raise the rule good guesses 7 8
8 does not increasing numbers is the
rule and I love this there's a language
philosopher by the name of grace and he
has this cool theory about how we speak
to each other and one of his big ideas
is that we are specific to the extent
that we need to be in the situation and
so could say hand me your coffee mug
and I would know what he was talking
about
and he would be unlikely to say hand me
your silver coffee mug unless there was
a another coffee mug on the table that
was not silver and lawyers and
politicians and others use this in very
clever ways to say things that are kind
of in logic terms true but where the
implicature what any reasonable listener
would infer is not what actually is the
case and I like this example a lot
because by seeing two four eight I mean
I think the thing that left out to all
of us immediately is these numbers are
doubling and it's really tempting to
either give an example that's another
doubling or as we saw a three 981
something that's the the squares and
what I liked about five to six and this
is pretty rare actually it's like is
that it did you think 5 to 6 was going
to work well why did you pick something
it wasn't going to work
very test the edge cases and this is
this is what I think we need to do a lot
more of in design and it's shockingly
rare I showed this slide in a top
universities computer science colloquium
that particularly has a really strong
theoretical computer science department
it was not Cornell and a vittatus
different place and we were on the slide
for like 40 minutes because people jut
they would be like they kept up with the
most esoteric formulas yeah how could we
actually know the world the roll is kind
of arbitrary to whatever you do want it
to be because it matches several rules
so I don't know what rule is right
unless I prove it to get it so don't
know what to do this right so does
another but it reminds me of visual
design there should be no differences
unless the differences yeah totally and
it's like small multiples there's
differences there communicate
unless they do yeah and this I wanted to
use for exactly that reason that one
challenge we get when we have just one
data point is that you can hallucinate
lots of different stuff into it and
depending on how the coin toss is go you
could end up with a data point where the
natural inference is something that's
different than what's actually going on
and so the only way to figure out what's
going on is to is to poke at it and in
particular I think the takeaway from
this example is poke at it in a way that
you hope will fail rather than in a way
that you hope will succeed and for all
PhD students I think this is where
thinking about is could you design your
study to think to show where the thing
breaks as opposed to I'm afraid of the
boundary conditions so that stays safely
in the middle where I'm pretty sure it's
gonna work because all you know
everything breaks eventually man
speaking of everything breaks eventually
our our the third meaning of question
makers is that one thing that we can do
with I think this vocabulary is to start
to question makers as happened for
Facebook CEO Mark Zuckerberg about a
year and a half ago now and I thought I
mean I've now watched this testimony and
read the transcripts a whole lot I think
there's a lot going on there there's
other people more qualified than me to
dive in on a lot of topics but one of
the things that I thought was
interesting is that the gist of what
Zuckerberg conveyed in part of his
testimony it was you know I started this
thing in my dorm room I never would have
thought in a million years that a decade
from now our biggest problem was going
to be Russian hackers and as such I
think that's actually an extremely
reasonable statement that when you
starts up the Uni dorm room you don't
you know you wouldn't think that was
going to happen and
I think the the statement is also a
little bit disingenuous and that it kind
of collapses all the time in between the
dorm room and now and it's the inductive
failure of you say well on day one I
shouldn't have worried about Russian
hackers on day two wasn't yet reasonable
to worry about Russian hackers therefore
we should never worry about pressure and
hackers by conduction and you know I
think all of us don't buy that it's a
much harder question to ask well what
when should you another example I think
that is interesting in terms of things
shaking out differently than the
optimists hope is this is actually this
is totally accidental Morgan Ames as an
alum from here and I mean I love her
work on One Laptop Per child and in
preparing this I wanted to figure out
what the best way to site it was and her
book actually comes out I think Monday
or something like that and I think one
thing that is interesting about this
about Negroponte ii and friend's goal of
having a cheap laptop that is
pervasively used to improve education
worldwide is that i to the best of my
knowledge morgan would know a lot better
than me they never asked 5 to 6 and i
think that that's a really important
thing to ask and i think this leads to
you know in preparing this for today i
read a bunch of critiques of design and
one I think one pervasive worry about
design that's in the zeitgeist right now
is that it's all icing no cake that you
know you just run around with a bunch of
post-it notes but really you're not
going to understand that the deep
problems and when I thought that was
interesting about that and also being
back here on sabbatical is that you know
Terry wrote this great book in 95 called
bringing design to software and at the
time human centered design was not
terribly common in industry and
the message of that book was hey we
could do a lot better by folks if we
applied more human centered design
principles and I think that I still
share that insight I think that's that's
right and one thing that I think is
interesting is that it's a lot easier to
by the way my project of this talk today
is not to try and sell design as a good
thing or a bad thing but to try and pull
apart what some of the pieces might be
also I think you could use the word
design to cover a lot of different
things and I have no interest in the
project of which one is the real meaning
you know that said I think it's a lot
easier to borrow the trappings of a
field than to actually borrow the
substance and so you know I have an
undergraduate degree in art semiotic sin
part of that field has a lot of long
fancy words like hegemonic and what you
see is that sometimes people borrow the
vocabulary of the field without
understanding the undergirding ideas
that led to that vocabulary and we see
the same thing of assignment you know
it's easy to be optimistic and stick
post-it notes on the wall but but that
doesn't necessarily bring along the
substance with it one of the things that
I think is the most valuable technique
is it's called the perspective
retrospective there are actually there's
two references that I've been trying to
track down unsuccessfully one of them is
I'm looking for a good pull quote from
Mark Zuckerberg that that summarizes
what I just said it's writing the the
sentiment of it is is more diffuse I in
my mind there's a poll quote that that
has it a lot more concisely if you find
that send it to me or from anybody
doesn't need to be from him I just
thought that happened to be a high
profile case of questioning makers and
the other one is that there's a business
consultant who has this great article
with Danny Kahneman where they talk of
about the benefits and limits of
expertise and the consultant has this
idea called if anybody finds this
article let me know I was like in a
magazine fifteen years ago it has this
idea of a perspective retrospective and
the gist of it is that at the outset of
a project or you know and at various
points along the way ask the question if
this all goes south what would be the
most likely cause of that and can we can
we poke it that in some way now and so
you know ed for any project better than
I think that I've also seen that called
a pre-mortem same idea same idea yeah he
happened to call it this in my mind you
know there's reasons to doubt my mind
yeah right and right but that gets the
question of and I think this pre-mortem
is extremely valuable and way underused
and it's kind of funny because I do
think that the the pre-mortem the
perspective retrospective has what it
does is it's it's like the metacognitive
learning strategies that we avoid
because they're hard in that at the
outset of a praat of a long process why
earth you'd have to be a SATA is to
think about what the failure case is
gonna be I mean you got a hard you got a
tough row to hoe no matter what now if
you think about your future self you're
a lot better off dealing with the hard
thing now than later we're not always so
good at doing that but you know that
nonetheless is true that mystery of why
we're not so we're why we don't do as
good a job
doing right by our future selves as we
might is the mystery of Dan Gilbert's
fantastic book stumbling on happiness I
got it as a gift years ago never read it
and then one day did because they were
title just seemed stupid and it's a
brilliant brilliantly creative book I
loved it and so you know that what this
says to me is that questions are a form
of productive doubt and at SFMOMA right
now I think one of the major functions
of art is to ask questions and in
speculative design closer to our field
has done a brilliant job of this this is
a photograph by Richard Moss and what
he's done is he's taken infrared
photographs of migrant camps in
particular in the west of France right
about near the tunnel to the UK and
what's neat about these is that they
make visible through infrared
photography something that and telephoto
lenses an area that journalists are
forbidden from going into and so the
world has said hey we don't want you to
or the government has said hey we don't
need to see this stuff and he's like
well what would the world think if they
did and so he makes these photographs I
mean also did a lot that's interesting
that's going on they're kind of using
military technology to to question it
it's really there just visually really
neat to see what pops out and infrared
and I think a lot of successful in art
and design works on those multiple
levels you know there's the the
conceptual level of turning the tools
against against themselves of seeing
something you can't see
and like gosh they're just visually
really cool and in some cases pretty
intense but it's a really neat example
of art asking questions and maybe them
the most surprising things that
shouldn't have been about all the work
that we've done with Creative Learning
online is the benefit of diversity
in terms of students seeing what other
students do and there was a narrative
with online learning that I think both
the enthusiasts and the detractors
latched onto early which is that once we
figure this out we're only gonna need
one person to teach the class that
Manish is the best person to teach in
this and so we'll just record him and
run with it and I think there's there's
a sense of that which has some merit
like I really like saw Khan's
explanation of the chi-squared test and
I wasn't able to like get it short in a
way that 300 students could you know I
just couldn't do it right and then I
watched all Khan's video and in like
three and a half minutes you get the
whole thing super easily it's like it's
like wonderfully economical so now I use
actually what in that case what I do is
I teach it live and I thanks hat tip saw
saw for the the structure of that in
other in it but I think that actually
even that case what's interesting is
that I looked at several and somebody
else might pick a different one and in a
lot of cases what we're now seeing is
that it used to be that if you were at
place a you only got two hurt here
person a you know if you're not at
Stanford you don't get to here bill for
plank but when things move online then
you get this visibility and so now you
can look at multiple perspectives or
pick and choose and that's true both for
students and for teachers here's two
pieces of student work from an art class
where the prompt is the same one from
Norway one from Canada so the prompt is
the same the latitude is the same but
they're halfway around the world and the
solutions are really different and I
just think that's super cool actually
skip that because we get the idea there
so it's really corny joke gonna tell
every year I'm sure I got it from Kelly
or something like that
how many designers does it take to
change a lightbulb
and there's several answers to it one is
you don't need a light bulb you need a
new illumination experience and it it's
a gentle way of poking fun at design
bringing its wares more upscale but I
also think it's like fundamentally right
and true in a deep way and the sign of
the architecture professor and
crowdsourcing researcher Jeff Nickerson
at the collective intelligence
conference a year or so ago and the way
that he described this I thought was
really great which is he says that you
know what's happening here is there's a
negotiation around the valuation
criteria and I think a ripe area for
inquiry and and one critique that you
could have of the the simulated
annealing sketch that I showed at the
beginning is that the sketch I showed at
the beginning implies that your y-axis
is fixed and I think one of the most
interesting things about design standing
in for a whole lot of creative fields I
mean it in a small D sense although here
small B anyway is that part of what one
does I mean even when you're you're
working on your own is that is you
change the y-axis as you go along you
know you're interested in getting a
denis I just got this coffee mug
yesterday and you know you change what
things you seek as you as you go along I
originally thought I wanted the cheapest
one possible which meant borrowed one
from the friend that I'm staying with I
realized that lid was not gonna stay on
and so he changed the y-axis cheapest as
possible I don't care what it is is not
the right choice and these shifts in
representation and the shifts and the
goals I think are really are
super interesting this is my favorite
recent example of redesigning a brief
this is an instrument it's called the
Umbra it's a metal tined instrument
they're pervasive throughout Africa
especially in Tanzania in places like
that
traditionally they'll have you know a
dozen ish keys this one has 20 I think
which is on the high side and there were
traditionally played inside a gourd that
you grew your own speaker box and which
also meant that the the playing was
invisible to the audience which is kind
of cool and I got introduced through a
violinist friend of mine to Bill Wesley
and Patrick Hadley who make this
instrument is a really weird thing I was
at an art opening last January and saw
this instrument and thought it was the
coolest thing I'd ever seen nobody was
playing it at the time I had no idea
what it was
about six weeks later a violinist friend
of mine was over for dinner and she's
like you know Scott what you need to
play is the embarrass me this thing I
was like wow her good friend of hers
makes them and I've gotten to be friends
with Patrick and Bill and they were kind
enough to when I bought an instrument
from them mentor me and in making the
instrument myself and so this particular
in birra
is Patrick and Bill's design and I under
a good watchful eye from Patrick
actually physically built this one which
means there's a couple errors in here
but and I wanted to give you a feel for
what it sounds like we'll see how this
goes here all right so it's a what's
neat about this instrument is that in a
piano your notes go low to high so this
would be the lowest note and this would
be the highest note but actually as you
can see this left note over here is
pretty high and this one's pretty low
instead what Bill's invention was to
take the octaves and clump them together
and so here we have all of our apps are
together all of ceaser together and then
you say wait a minute
who put F next to see if they screwed it
up and what's neat is that this user
interface change switches what Bill
believes in what he's either brainwashed
or convinced me of is that the piano is
a terrible user interface who only fools
use that thing and a much better user
interface is to organize things
conceptually so this embeds a number of
different music theory principles I
pulled you know I think one of the most
salient is that as you go rightward you
get fifths and as you go up and to the
left you get fourths but there's like a
bunch of them I mean it's like
numerology and a keyboard and there's a
PDF at array and beer accom where you
can see all of them it's the coolest
nistrim and I'll be around all day if
anybody wants to play it and so I played
a song with a friend and that's right so
[Music]
ah there we go and then you can go
anyway but it's really beautiful and or
that and so one thing that's really neat
is that because many pop songs are
grabbing a small number of notes that
run across fifths it can be relatively
easy to decode kind of the main hook of
a pop song and so I had one of my head
the other day it's always hard to switch
songs right
[Music]
and you can know what that song is no it
is a little tough road yeah and what's
neat about this is that every let's see
so it's right you start on the D here is
that these five notes which are the
right word and fifth sequence are the
whole part of the hook and it's shocking
how many pop songs you can you can
figure out to that first approximation
this way it's also interesting I got
cocky after I learned a Jamie taught me
a Dylan song and I was like ah he's like
one of the great songwriters of all the
time if I can play this Dylan song I
play this Stevie Wonder song that I like
and so I look up the stuff for Stevie
Wonder I can't even read it I have no
idea what's happening there and so it's
neat to be able to look under the hood
and see what's simple and what's
different but the the last thing I
wanted to show here is that right so I
played this hook here starting on the a
and Jamie invited me to play the show
and I had never played in front of an
audience before and I arrived and she's
like hey I got bad news the bassist
couldn't play it in the key that we
practiced and so we shifted it to a
different key and on the piano that
would screw up all of your motor memory
because what becomes white keys or black
keys and it's just a big mess what's
neat about this is that to shift the key
simply means shifting right or left and
the hurdle for me playing was not the
details of the key but the idea that I'm
barely learning this
I'm gonna stand in front of people and
so Jamie was like if you don't want to
do it that's fine and I was like no I
got over the hard part this is the you
know it's like if you're gonna climb
Everest I'd be like oh we only have red
jackets you're like yeah that wasn't
that that wasn't the issue and because I
was a little nervous I put sticky dots
on the key anchor points and so after
Jamie told me that we switched the key
what I did is I went outside and I just
moved the sticky anchor points one to
the right and and and all of the motor
memory was was exactly the same and I
think this is for me the coolest example
of how a design can instantiate some
really important and useful theory in a
way that the the user doesn't always you
know benefits from knowing that but
doesn't need to in order to be able to
do something useful how many people have
written this embedding that many people
here have T aid or a taught or given a
friend feedback on something this is uh
it says awk in the top left there raise
your hand if you've ever written awk and
this is a better audience than most good
for you all Nancy Somers who's on the
education faculty at Harvard as this
wonderful book about student writing and
when I was there a couple years ago she
and I got talking and a key theme of her
work is that the feedback that we give
makes sense in our heads but it doesn't
make sense to the person who receives it
and I was like oh that sounds almost
exactly like human centered design yeah
I got you it's hard to design stuff that
the other person can make sense of an
awk is not terribly useful feedback
because for the same challenge that I
caricatured at the at the beginning with
when your first app flops do you change
the fonts do you
give up on design entirely do you do
something in-between with awk does it
mean the grammar is is janky here does
it mean I don't believe the argument
it could mean lots of different things
and good feedback is specific actionable
and and justified so here you've got
Nancy sitting next to a student and this
is great but how can you scale or you
know you think earlier about the example
from John soon with with with the
architecture student Petra and you think
well how do you scale that one thing
that I see is that a lot of errors are
variations on a theme and so as I'm
noodling around in this instrument the
mistakes that I make some of them are
extremely common and if you plot this as
kind of a long tail you can say well you
know the really common mistakes that we
make I mean my conclusion from this is
that we should put a lot of resources in
this is where you have like the IMAX
experience explaining the conceptual
error if everybody's got the question
you can put a lot of resources into
coming up with a good explanation then
there's stuff that's somewhat common and
then there's going to be stuff that is
extremely unique or or rare I recently
hung a porch swing and I wanted rope
that looked looked old-timey but we've
had modern materials so it would be more
waterproof and stuff like that and I
didn't know what size rope I needed to
be able to hang the swing and store I
started googling around for for some
heuristic and and pretty quickly when
you want newfangled stuff that looks old
you end up on a sailing website but of
course what holds a boom
is just a different challenge than I
have and most of the uses of this rope
wherefore were for sailing and then and
so I googled around a little bit more
and I was on my phone and I get this
weird warning message and I'm like
whatever and I look at the discussion
board and it was great and I'd stumbled
across a bondage website where they
offered a night apparently hipster
bondage I guess because they for this
rope they were like okay good heuristic
is that if you want to hold you know
have the rope hold five times the
person's body weight and I was like okay
great so I want to be able to have two
people you think about who my friends
are and how much they weigh you do five
times that and you got your rope all of
a sudden and so this ability to get
peer-to-peer answers for the more
esoteric cases I think is really
valuable and so you're gonna see
different strategies depending on
whether it's the common case or a more
unusual case and a way that you can help
match those things is attrition noon and
Haley Fraser and Arielle Weingarten with
marathon trip and I built a system that
we showed a chi maybe two years ago
called critique it and what that does is
it helps you reuse feedback from other -
do we go to 12:30 or 12:15 12:30 oh
great alright I could talk a lot more
thanks for letting me know it used to be
a longer one good thing I'll take
questions Thanks
[Applause]